OF A WASHINGTON STATE FLORIST
WHO DECLINED WHEN A LONG-TIME
CUSTOMER OF HERS ASKED HER TO DO
FLOWERS FOR HIS SAME-SEX
CEREMONY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LEGAL
ARGUMENTS.
SENIOR CLINICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING.
YOUR REACTION TO THIS RULING.
>> I THINK YOU ARE CORRECT WHEN
YOU SUGGEST THAT WHILE IT'S NOT
AN NARROW VOTE, IT'S AN NARROW
HOLDING IN THE SENSE THAT IT
APPLIES FOR INSTANCE IN WHICH
THE COURT FOUND THAT THIS BAKER
DIDN'T GET A FAIR HEARING.
THE COLORADO CIVIL RIGHTS
COMMISSION WAS SO BIASED AGAINST
HIM AND BIASED AGAINST THE
BAKER'S RELIGIOUS CONVICTIONS
AND BELITTLED THOSE CONVICTIONS,
DESCRIBING THE ARGUMENT AS
DESPICABLE, THAT IT WASN'T A
FAIR HEARING AND COULDN'T STAND
PRETTY GIVE SOME RECOGNITION TO
THE IDEA THAT RELIGIOUS
CONVICTIONS MAY BE A REASON TO
DENY SERVICES IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES MIGHT BE.
A BIT OF FLORIST CASE WILL TELL
US MORE.
>> Shannon: TO THE OTHER LEGAL
ISSUES, THERE PRESIDENT AND
WHETHER OR NOT HE CAN PARDON
HIMSELF.
THE CONSTITUTION DOESN'T SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT BUT HE'S
GETTING A WARNING FROM HIS OWN
TOP LAWYER.
>> RUDY GIULIANI WAS SAYING
YESTERDAY.
SAYING IT WOULD BE DISASTROUS.
HE POINTED OUT THAT IF YOU
PARDON HIMSELF, PARDONS DON'T
APPLY TO IMPEACHMENT.
AND THE QUESTION OF WHETHER HE
CAN PARDON HIMSELF REMAINS AN
OPEN QUESTION IN THE SENSE THAT
PARDON POWER IS PRETTY SWEEPING
AND THE PRESIDENT CAN EXERCISE
IT AS HE SEES FIT.
BUT IT'S NEVER BEEN EXERCISED IN
A CASE WHERE A PERSON, A
PRESIDENT IS PARDONING HIMSELF.
THE CONSTITUTION IS SILENT ON
IT.
THERE IS A PRINCIPLE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE WHICH IS THAT NO
PERSON SHALL BE THE JUDGE OF HIS
OR HER OWN CASE.
THIS WOULD SEEM TO FLY IN THE
FACE OF THAT.
IT'S A DOUBTFUL PROPOSITION THAT
HE COULD PARDON HIMSELF.
>> Shannon: IT GOES ALONG WITH
THE ADVICE THAT YOU SHOULDN'T BE
YOUR OWN LAWYER.
YOU CAN'T BE YOUR OWN JUDGE.
THERE IS THIS ISSUE, 1974
DECISION CAME FROM WITH IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> THIS GOES TO THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT COULD BE
INDICTED BY ROBERT MILLER.
IN THE NIXON ERA, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, LEGAL COUNSEL,
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IN-HOUSE
ATTORNEY DETERMINE THAT A
PRESIDENT, A SITTING PRESIDENT
COULD NOT BE INDICTED.
IT WAS LOOKED AT IN 2,000 BY THE
SAME OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL,
DIFFERENT PEOPLE CAME TO THE
SAME CONCLUSION.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFERED
LEGAL OPINIONS LIKE THAT ARE NOT
BINDING LAW.
THEY ARE BINDING ON THE
DEPARTMENT.
SINCE ROBERT MUELLER IS A
CREATURE OF THAT DEPARTMENT, NOT
AN INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, SPECIAL
COUNSEL WORKING FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, PRESUMABLY THOSE
OPINIONS WOULD BE BINDING UPON
HIM.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT IF THE
PRESIDENT WAS DETERMINED BY THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL 12 COMMITTED
SOME CRIME FOR WHICH HE COULD BE
IMPEACHED, HE COULD THEN BE
INDICTED.
IF HE WAS FOUND TO HAVE
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE, ONCE HE IS
IMPEACHED, HE'S NOT IN OFFICE
AND THE OPINION DOESN'T APPLY.
HE COULD BE TRIED.
>> Shannon: THOSE ARE THE LEFT
RAISING THE CRY SAYING THAT HE'S
AN IMPERIALIST, HE'S GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING FOR HIMSELF AND
PARDON HIMSELF, THE CONSTITUTION
WIDELY PROVIDES HIM THAT.
>> THE ARGUMENT BEING MADE THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS DECLARING
HIMSELF ABOVE THE LAW.
IMPEACHMENT IS A CORE PART OF
THE LAW.
SO LONG AS HE IS VULNERABLE,
SUSCEPTIBLE, SUBJECT TO
IMPEACHMENT, HE'S NOT ABOVE THE
LAW.
>> Shannon: HE AND HIS
ATTORNEYS MAINTAIN IT'S A MOOT
QUESTION.
HE HAS DONE NOTHING WRONG AND
THEY ARE CONFIDENT THAT'S WHAT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WILL FIND
GREAT >> I THINK IT'S THE SILLY
ISSUE.
THE BIG IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
COULD BE CALAMITOUS POLITICALLY.
>> Shannon: I THINK IT WAS
THAT CHAIR OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY MITTIE CHUCK GRASSLEY